good afternoon my name is Anna Kate
Regan I'm majoring in American Studies
and I'm currently a sophomore our
speaker today Robert ASA Rico is
co-founder and president of the Acton
Institute for the Study of religion and
liberty and the pastor at Sacred Heart
of Jesus Parish and Academy he received
his Master of Divinity degree from the
Catholic University of America following
undergraduate study at the University of
Southern California and the University
of London he has written for numerous
publications including the New York
Times The Wall Street Journal Forbes the
Financial Times the Detroit News and The
Washington Times he has been a guest on
numerous television and radio programs
on CNN ABC CBS MPR and the BBC among
others a member of the Mount Pelion
society the American Academy of religion
and the Philadelphia society
Reverend sirico is the author of
defending the free market the moral case
for a free economy please join me in
welcoming Robert Reverend Robert Sirico
to the stage
well it's good to be in Jerusalem
I am really so delighted to to be with
you tonight and I have a number of
students from my parish school Sacred
Heart Academy who are here it just seems
to be a nice symbionts especially given
the fact that oh I'll just guess 80% of
our teachers are graduates of Hill sale
as well so it's a good good product here
when I was in seminary lo those many
years ago taught by the Apostle Paul I
think part of our curriculum part of our
formation wasn't just academic there was
that dimension to it but it's also
pastoral how do you deal with people and
part of the work that I was assigned to
do in one year was to work with the poor
and this meant I was at Catholic
University of America in Washington DC
and we would go and serve the poor in
the inner city of the inner city of
Washington DC which meant Anacostia and
here's how it went on Fridays a seminary
buddy of my and myself would go get on
the training subway and go to Anacostia
and there we met a sister who ran a soup
kitchen in the basement of a Baptist
Church and she was very entrepreneurial
what she did was she contacted all of
the churches in Chevy Chase and the
various areas of surrounding Washington
DC and so she'd write to the
Presbyterians lady auxilary or the Lady
Baptists a Baptist group or the Catholic
grocery Society or whatever it was and
she said we need from you 300 meals once
a year your ladies can make food for 300
people and we will serve them so I
imagined what went on was that the the
ladies in
the Holy Rosary Society of Chevy Chase
Maryland would give the recipe to their
maids and the maids would prepare the
dinner and hand it to the chauffeurs who
would drive it down to us in Anacostia
now I don't know that that really
happened but this was my my Brooklyn
fantasy going on here and the
seminarians would arrive sister said to
us said to us now here's what we do here
your job is to set up the tables put out
the food make sure it's warm and heated
put out the food clean up after you're
done clean the whole thing up and
remember whosoever will may come we
don't ask anybody any questions about
their status their life or anything they
just come and they get something to eat
and so that was the agreement and we did
that and usually what would happen is
we'd set it up and we get it going and
then we could sit down and maybe have a
meal with people who were there and
different chores I remember once I was
bundling together some garbage and went
out to put it in the trash bin and I
noticed that a cab pulled up and two
ladies got out and they had shopping
bags with them and I just kind of greet
him I said hi she said well every time
to eat I said yeah she said can we get
to the front of line because we have to
go there's a sale we need to make i said
whosoever will may come sure ladies
so they went downstairs and and we would
work this and one Friday Joe and myself
my classmate were finishing up and we
hadn't eaten anything because the
Baptist lady sent chili on a Friday in
Lent right so good Catholic boys you
know and I said Joe you know when we get
back to the seminary the sisters are
gonna have closed down the kitchen so if
we're gonna get something to eat
we better get something before we get
home and I said there's a fish and chips
place I saw right down the street maybe
we can go there and get something to eat
and he said okay well go do that so we
went to the fish and chips place it was
after the lunch hour and as we walked in
there was a man kind of cleaning up the
tables and sweeping out things and young
girl helping him and he came over to the
table and took our order and I noticed
he passed it through the kitchen window
and there was a woman in there and she
was frying up the the fish and
immediately I realized so this is a
family and then it dawned on me this is
a family who lives in this neighborhood
this is a family that lives in this
neighborhood who run a business in this
neighborhood and I am their competitor
on Fridays
the advantage I had is that we didn't
have to pay for our food we didn't pay
for the insurance we didn't pay any of
the salary to anybody sister work for
free we work for free no light bills
nothing like that we had no no problem
this family on Fridays had less
customers because we were there doing
charitable work in their neighborhood
and we never asked anybody who came to
us what they needed not sitting there
eating with my seminary buddy and I said
Joe a thought has just crossed my mind
he said what he said I said weirdest
guys competitors we're making life more
difficult for this family in this
neighborhood he said you're a heretic I
said no no think about it he said well
what are we supposed to do he was from
Brooklyn - what are we supposed to do I
said I'm not sure I'm this thought is
just occurring to me it's a very
uncomfortable thought because we have
all the best intentions in the world we
want to help these people but the
problem is we don't know these people we
don't know the kind of help that they
need and we don't ask them we don't ask
them to contribute anything we don't ask
them to bring a little fool realness
that helped us set up we don't ask them
to help us clean up we don't know
anything about them there's no rationing
of any sort going on that a price system
would normally provide for that has
always remained a question for me how do
we combat that so my topic today is to
talk about Christianity social justice
and poverty and that thought immediately
came to my mind the complexities of
serving people serving the vulnerable
serving the poor you see it's not
good intentions we need something else
we need if we're talking about feeding
people if we're talking about people who
are poor then we're talking about
economics we have to bring sound
economics to questions of good
intentions and if we don't we can make a
real mess of the whole thing somebody
wrote a whole book on this whole poverty
that hurts or kills so that was my
seminary experience in the soup kitchen
long before I founded the Acton
Institute of the Acton Institute in a
lot of ways grew out of that concern
that I began to see on many many many
levels not just soup kitchens in inner
cities we need something more than good
intentions I want to talk first about
the nature of Christianity because
that's the moral backdrop in which a lot
of people debate these kinds of
questions even if it's not an explicit
religious argument you notice that when
we have political arguments about the
cost of education the cost of health
care the questions of shelter and
clothing and the well-being of people it
all takes place in front of the backdrop
of a moral question what ought to we we
be doing as a society what kind of a
society is a moral society what kind of
a society is this I as society
appropriate to human dignity that's
that's really the question that we're
facing in many many ways and
Christianity in particular of course
when I say Christianity I mean it in its
judeo-christian reality because
Christianity is the the younger daughter
of Judaism the the the Jewish people the
Jewish covenant being the inheritance of
Christianity and the whole anthropology
the whole view of the human person that
comes out of this biblical idea and it's
really incredible when you think about
what these ideas formed
and what they grew into over a period of
roughly two three thousand years in
Christianity what is the main claim of
Christianity is that God became one of
us
he joined at a certain point in time and
entered human history that the eternal
God commingled with the human race and
not from outside the world but he broke
out of the material world in the
incarnation when he was born in
Bethlehem think about what that means
that in the beginning was the word and
the Word was with God the prologue of
John's Gospel and the word became flesh
this in flesh meant is the core
foundation it's the way in which
Christianity views everything else about
itself it's sacraments it's social
engagement it has to do with the
goodness of the material world and in a
real sense this is a reiteration of the
book of Genesis this is why I think it's
very important to keep Judaism and
Christianity together you can't separate
the two in the Garden of Eden when God
created man and woman he created them
after having formed all things from
nothing into being and pronounce the
material world good and then creates man
who is a composite of heaven and earth
the dust of the ground and the breath of
life and then gives man and woman as his
first word spoken to the human race in
the Garden of Eden the vocation and that
vocation is to tend the garden notice by
the way we won't get into
environmentalism but notice by the way
that it was a garden and not a jungle
and what's the difference the garden
needs tending the human being is not
unnatural to the environment they say
some people will argue that like we're
the only unnatural thing on the planet
everything else needs to be
that human life is dispensable but I
digress and yet it informs what we're
talking about because this view both of
the Old Testament of the book of Genesis
and in the New Testament and the
doctrine of the Incarnation says
something about the sanctity of the
material world that God had an intention
for the material world that he created
he reiterates that intention and the
Incarnation of his son and what begins
to happen what begins to unfold is not
just an idea an abstraction but an
institution it's called the church the
church confronts society and culture and
builds culture and confronts history
with a message of her savior part of
this message is the dignity of the human
person an anthropological vision that
each human being from the first moment
of their existence until their natural
demise is the possessor of a dignity
that each person is unrepeatable each
person is unique each person bears the
image of God the imago Dei each person
is created in that image of God for
eternity that is who the human person is
now that idea began to be fleshed out in
an institutional form and what that
meant was that when Christianity began
to confront human beings in their
vulnerability whether there were widows
whether they were orphans whether they
were profoundly handicapped or
near-death whether they were diseased
regardless of their race that the
Christian would always confront that
person as though they were confronting
Christ himself because jesus said that
to the extent that you do it unto one of
the least of these my brethren you have
done it unto me
so the encounter with the poor and the
mind and the assumption of the church
is an encounter with Christ himself and
we see this not just as a theological
concept but we see it very early in the
church's history even right outside of
the text of the scriptures we begin to
see it there was a plague that broke out
in the city of Antioch and there's some
historical material related to this
where the the Legion guard captain
whatever he was wrote back to Rome and
said look there's a plague that's broken
out it's spreading I've pulled back the
troops so that they wouldn't get caught
in the contagion of course the
politicians had already left he said and
even people's families even physicians
are leaving people because of this
contagion but one strange thing is
happening there are a group of people
this cult following Christ who are
staying with the dying and they're
tending to them at risk to their own
lives now this is just a a soldier
reporting to his superiors
right there of course you remember in
the Acts of the Apostles in Antioch
that's where they would call Christians
for the first time they're living out
what Christ did himself this intuition
to associate oneself with a dying with a
vulnerable with the poor with the broken
because of Christianity's belief in the
Incarnation the seriousness with which
God took history and culture and the
material world began to form itself into
institutions first very small very
informal it would happen oh I think in
the early Middle Ages that people when
plagues would break out or people were
dying they would bring them to convents
and very often the convents would have
some extra room
and they would bring the dyeing they say
we don't know what to do with these
people
medicine was very primitive would you
take care of them and so they would
receive the men and the sisters would
take care of them and in the process of
taking care of them they would develop
systems of sanitation cleaning
refreshing the bed keeping air
circulating the sisters and monks did
this too they began also to prepare
these very primitive recipes that were
medicinals today we enjoy them they're
called limoncello sambuca chateaus all
these wonderful DJ's DVDs but these
really all of these things were
originally medicines herbal medicines to
help people and hidden this they they
began to work with people and they found
some things work better than others and
this was first called hospices and then
later in more institutionalized forms
hospitals the invention of hospitals is
a Christian invention not only that but
consider this that institutionalized and
internationalized organized charity is
the result of Christianity because of
the organizational system of the church
and the various places that the church
existed and the idea that charity was
done not to people because they were
Christians charity was done because we
were Christians because we could
encounter Christ anywhere human life is
sacred these ideas came out of this
anthropology of this cosmology that we
find in the Old Testament in the New
Testament
universities come out of this experience
if you read any of the great historians
of of ideas today we are her ranked by a
secular culture that's trying to tell
the church how to do charity when
institutionalize charity is our
invention and all they have are
secularized desiccated forms of charity
that aren't even that generous and
certainly aren't even that effective and
here's why because what Christian
charity did in connection with the poor
was to see the person as a whole being
that is to say that they were material
they had needs if they were hungry or if
they were sick or if they were tired or
if they were whatever it happened to be
to tend to those material needs but that
there were something more than that
they were also transcendent beings they
were also beings destined for eternal
relationship with God there were
spiritual beings and there's holistic
view of who the human person was gives a
fuller understanding of how to deal with
that person in other words to put it a
different way
unlike secularist forms of charity we
don't treat people just as though they
were animals just as though they were
material when an animal is cold you take
it in out of the cold and put it in the
barn when it's hungry you give it some
hay when its thirst you bring it to the
trough because that's the total
existence of an animal it's material the
human being transcends the material they
are material but there's something more
than physical and because of that there
is love there is bonding there's an
understanding that when a person comes
to us and need that there's a whole
context that my
be provided and not just the material
the material again is important but it's
not the whole thing and the secularist
versions that only when they confront
poverty very often in the form of a
young woman who has become pregnant and
outside of marriage and has been kicked
out of her home and doesn't have a high
school education
what will the welfare state do it will
give her an abortion or it will give her
contraception it will give her food
stamps it will give her some counseling
but it won't bond with her it can't bond
with her and this is why Christianity
knows something not just about poverty
but about the poor but there's something
else embedded in the biblical view of
human life that's very important and
that is that the material world is
sacred and can be the occasion for
honoring God and that the bearer of the
image of God also is bound to the world
primarily by their use of reason and
that we can work in this material world
so as to produce more than we consume
and this understanding of humanity is
very different than the zero-five-zero
some form of your manifold BIA that we
see at the United Nations and very often
in the halls of Congress the fear that
if there are more human beings on this
planet there's going to be less of the
pie for us to all eat it only sees the
human person as a mouth that consumes
and not also as a mind that produces
that is creative how can it be that a
man who has ten pigs is richer than a
man that has one but a man who has ten
children is seen as poorer than a man
that has one now we see the human person
is the source of creativity that man as
st. john paul ii once
man is man's greatest resource and that
too
marginalized the dignity of human life
and to see human life or more human life
children as a threat to economic
productivity is a fallacy and a
dangerous one at that how do we counter
this what do we do in the face of it we
deal with people who we know we bond
with people who have needs and needs
that because we know them we know their
needs this in my tradition is called the
principle of subsidiarity in the
reformed tradition the great reformed
theologian and statesman Abraham Kuyper
called it sphere sovereignty now there
are technical differences between sphere
sovereignty and subsidiarity but let me
articulate you what I know best that
this is in the form of the subsidiarity
what is talking about you it'll sound
very familiar to you basically what
subsidiarity says is that needs are best
met at the most local level of their
existence
this political societies of higher
complexity ought not to intervene in to
lower forms of society except in cases
of dire emergency and even then only
temporarily to put it simply needs are
best met at the most local level of
their existence to put it simply if I
have a need I have the first
responsibility to meet my need but if
there's some collapse in me for some
reason or another then it's my family's
responsibility to respond to that need
and if there's a collapse there then our
extended family our cousins our
relatives maybe our neighbors maybe our
churches may be other mediating
institutions in society that are
independent of the state all of these
need to be the first to be permitted to
act on behalf of those who have needs
precisely because these are the people
who know the people best they know if
there's a real need or if you're just
putting on an act they know what that
need is if it's a meal or it it's love
or if it's counsel or if it's a good
swift kick in the behind because we all
have different needs and unless we know
each other
the real sinister thing in Italian
sinistra means left by the way the real
sinistra the real sinister thing here is
that the welfare state in the name of
the poor disables the poor very often it
disincentivizes the rest of society to
act first because there's an intuition
because resources are scarce there's an
intuition that says well if their need
is going to be met by this group of
people or this agency or whatever then
I'll go and do something else and look
at what happens society begins to
fragment people are no longer bound
together by bonds of concern and love in
the way that Alexis de Tocqueville saw
when he visited the United States and
documented it in democracy in America
Americans always organizing themselves
in some kind of social group to meet
various kinds of needs no authentic
community is the result of a vibrant and
strict implementation of subsidiarity
this is the solution the wealth creation
of a free economy combined with vibrant
communities of moral concern without
regard to specific denomination I grew
up in Brooklyn New York and we had as
many different religions going on mostly
Jewish and Catholic okay I'll go then a
few Protestants were over there but they
lived another neighbor
but we work together on projects that we
saw as important because we were
neighbors
to one another we had a multi-ethnic
experience without a government mandate
to have one because we were generally
left free to form communities
Friedrich Basquiat in his wonderful
little book and any students here well
this is Hillsdale you probably already
read it the law by Friedrich Basquiat
it's on line take you an hour and a half
to read it's a wonderful book because it
doesn't teach you what to think it
teaches you how to think and one of the
things he talks about fraternity a
fraternity a fraternity Brotherhood one
of the things he says in that book is
you can't force people to be brothers to
the extent you force them they're no
longer brothers that it has to be
something that is free something that is
invited something that is compelled not
by government but by morality people
talk a lot about social justice today
it's a well used and abused phrase let's
remember that Aristotle gives us a very
clear definition of what justice is
justice is to be treated in accord with
dessert to the extent that there is
social justice it is society treating
society that is people communities of
people treating each other as they
deserve to be treated but let's be very
clear
societies don't act unless people act
societies can't be informed or imbued
with either vice or virtue it's people
who are the vicious over
to us so the extent that we're talking
about social justice we need to be very
careful that people aren't smuggling
into that idea the notion of socialist
justice which couldn't be more of an
oxymoron than anything else we see that
historically we see it today in
Venezuela we see it in North Korea we
see it everywhere that socialism has
been attempted in our world the
injustice of brutal regimes to decide
for people how their lives should go
the real temptation in a moral and a
morally sensitive heart is to respond to
people in the simplest way that they
know how let the government do it the
problem is the simplest way isn't always
the moral way the real way to build a
society that is just a society that is
imbued with a sense of something more
than justice a sense of charity a sense
of love is to allow people to get to
know one another to act freely and to be
formed by our moral vision this is not
an easy undertaking the depressing thing
is that the very people in our society
religious leaders in particular and
business leaders as well who ought to
understand how this works very often
don't understand how this works to see
religious leaders abandoning their
vocation to tend to the needs of the
poor to tend to the needs of Jesus
Christ who comes to us in de-stressing
disguises and hand that over to the
government is abominable and for
business leaders to likewise betray
their vocation to be creative and
productive with a talents that they have
been entrusted to entrusted with and
seeking the benefit and advantages of
state as an equal betrayal to the clergy
who abandoned their vocation to the
state now my friends we need a different
kind of society we need a society that
understands that piety is never a
substitute for technique I wish I had
written that line but I didn't
it's from H n Jill song it was a
philosopher he said if you want to build
a facade of a cathedral that represents
the rising of the soul to God like Notre
Dom you must first understand geometry
and then he said piety is never a
substitute for technique for without
technique piety is helpless to make use
of nature for the glory of God we need a
society that is imbued with a moral
sense and that as a high respect for the
technique of business a moral sense of
business a sense of business that is
imbued with the kind of anthropology
that I spoke of earlier CS Lewis spoke
so beautifully of this kind of
anthropological vision this vision of
the human person when he said you have
never met a mere mortal in the weight of
glory he wrote these lines you have
never met a mere mortal everyone whom
with whom you have ever come in contact
every shopgirl from whom you've ever
purchased anything anyone who you've
ever had a fight with anyone you've ever
quarreled with anyone you have ever
loved or hated is either an immortal
horror or an everlasting splendor but
you have never met a mere mortal and
then Lewis went on to say these words
the most sacred thing that presents
itself to our senses next to the Blessed
Sacrament itself is our neighbor this
anthropology comes from a
judeo-christian vision of how the world
was formed how human life came to be
and the dignity that each human bird
person possesses intrinsically in their
very nature this is the kind of society
that we must propose against the
ideology of division in class warfare
against the claims of Marxism and
socialism in its variants no we must
respond to such ideas with the insights
of someone like mother Teresa of
Calcutta who once said we should not
judge the rich we do not advocate class
struggle we advocate class encounter
where the rich save the poor and the
poor save the rich thank you very much
Thank You Reverend Sirico we now have
time for Q&A if you have a question
please make your way to the microphone
my question is would it be a good idea
for all people instead of just
physicians only to ask themselves before
they take an action first do no harm not
only would that be a good idea for
everyone to do it it would be especially
a good idea for physician physicians to
do it again today because I understand
that's been taken out of the Hippocratic
oath did you take that out of did you
take that vow do no harm I try to do you
think of nobody I mean as part of the
Hippocratic oath no sir
are you a physician no oh I'm sorry I
thought you were no I think they have
removed that in in the monitors but of
course yes first do no harm
absolutely absolutely
sir any consonant with what you have
said so very very well I just want to
make comment on a book by Samuel Cahill
an Irishman who wrote the book how the
Irish saved civilization and the last
sentence in that book after describing
all the st. Patrick and Columbo and
others did to rescue Christianity in
unlike on the continent the last
sentence is the ills of our of our world
will not be remedied by this by the
Romans that is the soldier but by the
Saints hmm
I believe that I believe that and I
think we need all we just celebrated
Saint All Saints Day on the 1st of
November we need to all be Saints I my
question is concerning wealthy
Christians or specifically Christian
business owners who have the power to
set wages and especially right there
just for a moment I'm gonna let you
finish but I think there's an assumption
that you've just made that is
economically erroneous so you said
business owners who have the power to
set wages how our wages set don't do the
the fat businessman with the cigar and
the tuxedo and the top hat say we will
pay them this may be if you so I was
wondering you know specifically
regarding the employees some of whom you
know might be in poverty or struggling
with cost of living how does a business
owner sort of navigate the teachings of
capitalism which would advise them to
maximize profit at all costs versus the
teachings of Jesus Christ which call
us to alleviate suffering and help those
in poverty good that's a good question I
stay there because I want to walk
through this with you this is kind of
like my soup kitchen it's it's filled
with the right intentions it's filled
with good intentions but this is why I
wanted to stop you at the first point
but now you've given me two or three
other points to work with so let's let's
kind of walk through this and see first
of all you're concerned with people who
have marginal income who have difficulty
with the cost of living you are
concerned with their wages which would
help them with their cost of living and
you're concerned with the business owner
who hires people and what he pays them
those things are interrelated intimately
interrelated and you see that because
you say well if we could raise their
income they could have more things that
they need in life but the way in which a
business owner decides what he charges
someone is the same competitive
principle as the wage earner in terms of
what he is going to buy in a given store
in other words the price of the good
that that wage earner produces the
worker produces is not arbitrarily
determined it's determined in context
with what the supply and the demand of
the service or the good or the the
products to produce the good is in other
words if an employer arbitrarily rose
raised the the wage scale of the worker
the worker would produce goods and
services that would also have to
increase in order to make that ends meet
that would mean that all the other
workers would have to go to the market
and buy those goods and services let me
finish and then you can come back they
would have to buy those goods and
services at
higher prices and they would have to
then go to their employers and ask for
more higher higher wages now if on the
other hand we allowed the prices of
goods and services to exist at the real
level that is the real cost of their
production whether it's in terms of
payment for employees or the harvesting
of the resources from society or
shipment or advertising whatever else it
is if we allow the price structure to be
free then we know what the real cost of
things is if we inflate it arbitrarily
we we distort all that now having said
all of that we still have people who
have a hard time making ends meet how
are we going to solve that problem
we're gonna solve that problem by
creating as productive and as wealthy as
society as we can where people who are
wealthy can both hire people but also
give to those people with the profits
that they have so it's all interrelated
and if we pull or obfuscate any one part
of it we throw the whole thing out of
coordination and then what ends up
happening is Venezuela is the Soviet
Union where you have an oversupply of
things that nobody wants and an under
supply of things that people desperately
want go ahead thank you for the response
but I sort of disagree with the I said
thank you for the response but I sort of
disagree with the premise so maybe a
concrete example would help so imagine
I'm a business owner I'll use round
numbers with like 50 employees who make
20,000 per year each which is a poverty
wage and that business profits me say
half a million dollars per year right I
could make the decision to forego a
certain amount of that profit say say
250,000
and pay each of my workers five thousand
dollars more per year which would
alleviate a lot of their suffering do
you think how you know what is how do
you see that problem what would you
advocate for a business owner to do and
that you know that wouldn't raise the
cost of the commodity okay mr. business
owner let me ask you this do you have
any ambitions to grow your business and
what portion of that how much did you
say you were making a half million yeah
what portion of that are you spending on
your boats and your cars and your rings
versus reinvesting in your business or
let me ask you a simpler question what
is the average profit of any given
business in this country you don't have
to be exact but give me an idea give me
a general idea because what's what's
your percentage of profit and that for a
$500,000 what's the percentage of your
profit
yeah about 2% 2% I'd invest in a company
for 2% yeah it's it's 2/3 percent they
got some economists here who could spit
this off very easily
it's it's not what you think it is the
this by the way you know I didn't say
this here but you read my book I was on
the left for from a number of years when
I was in my 20s I worked with Jane Fonda
and Tom Hayden in the campaign for
economic democracy come on it's my past
I've repented
I've repented I've gone to confession
they still want me to do the penance and
when I was talking with somebody the
thing he said to me that shocked me was
what do the richest people do with all
of their money I said well they they you
know have boats and they have rings they
have cars internet he said no the vast
majority of that money is invested in
business so what I'm suggesting to you
if you really were that business person
taking half of your profits would mean
you'd cut your growth of your business
by half which means your goods and
services that you provide to the market
in general will go up and your employees
would lessen in other words you wouldn't
be able to hire more you wouldn't able
be able to hire their cousins and their
their relatives is that okay
I'd like to continue but got other
people we could thank you what you're
saying earlier was basically to put on
the mind of Christ which is really hard
to do every day could you talk about it
I go to confession every other week yeah
anyway
I wonder if you could give us some
examples although you did say that doing
the work at the the localist level is is
the best way to meet the needs of the
people and get to know the people and
what their needs are but could you give
us some examples of some organizations
that that do it right that do it best
you know what are some good models for
us I will but let me just clear up one
kind of assumption that people always
have and here's my real heresy coming
out now here this is the big one
poverty is not solved by charity charity
needs to exist in extreme cases when
there's a dire need and whatever poverty
is solved not by charity not by even the
best charities but by business the
expansion of business the globalization
of business the world has risen in the
last 150 200 years out of poverty an
astounding rate if you look you've seen
this this is Hillsdale you've seen the
hockey stick right you've seen how most
people throughout all of history lived
at that level and then about 150 years
ago I began to go up and up and up and
shoot right through the roof and what
accounts for that is not charity
it's business business provides jobs the
great rabbi there was a medieval or
Renaissance rabbi
Maimonides had this ladder of charity
you know how to help people know the top
two levels are give that the most moral
thing is give anonymously and then the
top level is render a person on render a
person without need of your charity
business well done is the most
charitable thing that we can do now
having said that there are tons of
charitable organizations United
Scythians Salvation Army is a good
example in my parish we we take up a
second collection every week and that
money goes to the poor by which we mean
we have a group of about 20 people in
our parish and it's bound by our
geography so we don't send this money
all over the world it's just people we
can get to know and it's very leveraged
giving so if it's a working family where
the car is broken down we repair the car
if it's a family about to get evicted
for one reason or another we put the
deposit down on the thing and these
people get to know those people and we
invite them to come to church they don't
have to come to church but you know and
I've seen a few people show up in church
sometimes we'll help them with adoption
questions or child care questions and
things like that so it's not brain
surgery you know it's just really
getting to know people but there are
great organizations I can give you a
list of them so you were talking earlier
about how both a free-market framework
of business and also a local kind of
attempt to give charity is always going
to be superior to a top-down government
institution I mean I'd be interested to
hear an example where it isn't but no I
completely agree with that that seems
entirely true but in the world around us
right now there is definitely an
increasing enrichment of the massive
top-down institutional government
structures that you were talking about
and even more than that it seems like
they have a very different almost
antithetical anthropology of what the
human person is that's completely
different they have completely different
ideas of what the human good is and
despite a lot of outspoken voices
against it especially recently it seems
like it's growing at a very rapid pace
so on the ground what are some practical
tools that you suggest for fighting this
thing it seems it doesn't seem like it's
slowing down at all
right now yeah well I would make two
observations that the crisis is
horrendous
people don't understand who they are
they just really don't understand who
they are if you don't believe me I give
you drag queens story time I mean this
is just people and I don't mean just the
drag queens leave them alone I mean the
parents who bring the kids to these
things there is a deep anthropological
insanity in our society now that's the
bad side the good side is it can't last
but there's another bad side it can last
long enough to do a lot of damage what
is the solution that Hillsdale College
Sacred Heart Academy the academies the
schools the homeschooling parents the
other kinds of colleges like Hillsdale
all of these little platoons these
little groups of people who still assure
assure one another
we're not nuts they're nuts
and
and we have to build the wreck again you
know we have to build up from it but we
are advantaged in the sense that at
least we know some things I mean at
least Adam Smith wrote his book you know
The Wealth of Nations we know how this
thing works
so hopefully the the collapse won't be
as deep although you know it frightens
me here's what frightens me and if I
offend anybody here I can live with that
no but seriously what what's frightening
me is that some conservatives are
becoming very enamored status solutions
to things power tends to corrupt and
absolute power corrupts absolutely and I
don't care whether that's right-wing or
left-wing it's the power you have to
worry about when people get power and
don't let go of power when they when
there isn't a dispersion of power when
there isn't a kind of subsidiarity and
remember business people and to my
colleague my friend there who is talking
I am NOT canonizing business people as
such any more than I'm gonna canonize
the poor as such there are business
people who are greedy and who make deals
with people who can make deals
you know nobody comes to me I'd never
get a lobbyist they never come to me now
ask yourself why I don't hear from
lobbyists because I don't have political
power
that's why crony capitalism is
antithetical to real capitalism or at
least to real free markets let's use
that word because I don't like the word
capitalism so these are the things all
of this can be solved by right ideas and
so institutions like this are the place
to promote those right ideas and the
family
[Applause]
thank you so much for your talk it was
really beautiful
this question might be a little bit
silly given some of your last answers
but given your focus on local
institutions and things um would you see
distributism as a viable answer to the
welfare state no I don't I think
distributive ISM for those of you who
don't know what it is it's an it sees
itself as a third way between capitalism
and socialism and the articulation is
the best articulations I suppose of
distributive ISM come from GK Chesterton
who wrote remarkably little on the
subject and bellick and there are a few
other writers but these are the the
chief writers that people have reference
to today I think distributive ISM to the
extent that it is most cogent and
persuasive is not an economic theory
it's an aesthetic theory it tells us
that we can't be mechanized we can't be
subordinated to to just systems that we
have to be personal and creative and
cultivate authenticity but that's not an
economic system I think if we put in
place tomorrow
a real distributist model even an ideal
model to the extent that Chesterton has
any practical models which I don't think
he really does I think we would have
mass starvation in the world because we
need international corporations we need
large global industries not industries
that are bribing governments or being
subsidized by governments but we need
coordination internationally through a
market pricing a free pricing system and
distributive ISM wouldn't allow for that
it would make everything small small as
beautiful
according to the distributists and we
have two bigger world with more than six
billion people on the planet we need big
solutions to problems we don't need
micro loans we need macro loans we need
big industries and I think that can be
done in a moral way that can also have
an aesthetic that can critique the kind
of soulless business that the aesthetics
of distributive ISM seek to increase
criticise we have time for one more
question
thank you having so much fun it seems to
me that there is one word at the core of
any religion or at the core of our
nature describes it and that is
transformation we are asked to transform
ourselves but not to transform others we
can help others to transform themselves
that is what you seem to be laying out
am i close you're close you know who put
it very well let me see if I can get
this quote right because there's one of
these quotes that I always manage to
garble is Winston Churchill said that
the the socialism of Christianity said
no the socialism of today says whatever
is yours is mine and the socialism of
Christianity said whatever is mine is
yours it's a voluntary that's the secret
of the socialism if you want to use that
word which is anomalous because it's not
socialist it's this sense of sharing and
cooperation so I think that's what you
were saying this transformation thank
you very much for your time pleasure
being with you
you